Ryan Seacrest offers his well wishes 2x  julianne hough on her big day this is  fantastic  when you know you know and I just when  we saw each other for the first time I  was like and after Julian said I do too  husband Brooks like on Saturday at their  lavish Idaho wedding 42 year old Ryan  congratulated the Dancing with the Stars  judge on Mondays live with Kelly and  Ryan congratulations stunning and  there's also a photo of her father Bruce  and it's a you know I know this family  they are terrific people super talented  she is so congratulations Juliet  happiness Ryan and Julianne had a  two-year romance before calling it quits  in 2013 when the conversation turned to  his feelings on his former flame tying  the knot the talk-show hosts had the  best response but it's kind of being  here like what if an ex gets married  great oh no I've got several X's that I  got married  they're all married then they start  having kids